all right
hey everyone and welcome to
machine learning and fairness so i'm
hannah
and jen is here in the audience she's
going to
come up in a couple of minutes and we
are both machine learning researchers in
microsoft research new york city
and since most of you don't know us i
wanted to take a minute or so just to
tell you a little bit about
who we are and what we do okay
so as i said we're machine learning
researchers and we've each been doing
machine learning for about 15 years at
this point
working on a mix of theoretical and
applied projects
often in collaboration with social
scientists
over the past four years though we've
both become
increasingly interested in fairness
accountability
transparency and ethics as they relate
to ai and machine learning
we're both members of microsoft's fate
research group
which was formed in 2015 to focus on
exactly these
issues it's an inherently
socio-technical group
with core ai and machine learning
researchers like jen and myself
and researchers in the social sciences
policy
and the law jen and i are also both very
involved in microsoft
ai and ethics in engineering and
research committee or
ether where i co-chair the ether working
group on bias and fairness
and jen co-chairs the working group on
intelligibility
okay so i want to start by talking about
ai and machine learning
so as you all know machine learning is
super hot right now
and over the past 15 years or so we've
seen machine learning go
from some weirdo academic discipline
only of interest to machine learning
nerds like me
to something that's so mainstream that
it's mentioned on
billboards and even appears in web
comics and tv
shows if you don't believe me this graph
shows the number of registrations for
the largest machine learning conference
neural information processing systems or
eurips for short
from 2002 with around 600 registrations
to 2018 with eight and a half thousand
registrations
that sold out in 11 minutes and 38
seconds
yes really so at the risk of stating the
obvious
we're living in the age of ai machine
learning is everywhere and at least for
now
it looks like it's here to stay and this
is great
it means there are some amazing
opportunities for researchers like me
and jen for people with practical
machine learning skills
and for companies like microsoft and
indeed to put microsoft's
mission statement into practice we're
definitely going to need
ai and machine learning
but at the same time as all this
excitement we're seeing that these new
opportunities
also raise new challenges challenges
that have received a lot of attention in
the media
and have really highlighted how
important it is to get ai right
to make sure that ai does not
discriminate or further disadvantage
already disadvantaged groups
many of these stories have focused on
high-stakes decisions
where machine learning systems are used
to allocate opportunities
resources or information in ways that
can have significant negative impacts on
people's
lives so for example a couple of months
ago
amazon revealed that it had abandoned an
automated hiring system
after finding that the system amplified
gender bias
in the tech industry or as another
example
i'm sure many of you heard about the
pro-publica investigation
a couple of years ago which showed that
compass
a widely used recidivism prediction tool
was according to some metrics racially
biased
these biases can also affect more
mundane systems too
for instance in 2013 latanya sweeney
showed that online ads
suggesting that people had been arrested
appeared more often for distinctly black
sounding names
than for other names thereby reinforcing
negative stereotypes
of black criminality
so how do these stories relate to
fairness well broadly speaking they're
all examples of machine learning systems
causing harms to some people but not to
others
so in other words examples of machine
learning systems
behaving unfairly of course and this
will be a recurring theme throughout
this talk
fairness is a fundamentally societal
concept
that's been studied by philosophers
lawyers and social scientists
for hundreds of years moreover
there's no one-size-fits-all definition
of fairness
but suitable for all systems in all
contexts
so it's a bit daunting to be suddenly
grappling with fairness
throughout the tech industry that said
at least as we see it we're not
completely unprepared
in particular we can think about
fairness in a similar way
to the ways that we think about security
and privacy
first security and privacy are both
socio-technical challenges
as is fairness in the context of machine
learning
sure fairness is a little closer to the
socio end of the spectrum
but they're all on there second in the
tech industry
security and privacy are much older
topics than fairness
so we can really learn a lot from their
history
in particular in the late 90s and early
2000s
security and privacy efforts were very
competitive
adversarial and closed door and this was
driven by companies fears
of public criticism negative press and
financial costs
and by the assumption that it would be
possible to eliminate security and
privacy incidents
as a result the focus was very much on
prevention and detection
often post-deployment during the 2000s
though
this landscape changed considerably and
in fact microsoft was a leader in this
change
companies began to realize that there
was value in collaboration
cooperation and openness and began
working together
to prevent and detect vulnerabilities
now we've reached a point where the tech
industry acknowledges that it's
impossible to eliminate
security and privacy incidents of course
this doesn't mean that it's not worth
investing resources into prevention and
detection
but we must be prepared for such
incidents to occur
and must therefore also prioritize and
invest resources
into responding appropriately
i think that we can learn from this and
approach fairness with the same emphasis
on collaboration cooperation and
openness
of course we need to prevent our systems
from exhibiting biases
as best we can but we also need to
respond appropriately
when they inevitably do
to put it differently we need to adopt a
growth mindset toward fairness
just the security and privacy aren't
one-shot processes
and require continual evaluation and
improvement
fairness isn't a one-shot process either
we will make mistakes let's therefore
anticipate them as best we can
but when they do occur let's turn them
into something positive
specifically let's learn from them and
use them to improve our systems and
contribute to our successes
okay so with that background out of the
way we're going to cover four topics
today
that will collectively give you an
overview of fairness and machine
learning
we'll start by talking about some of the
main types of harm that can occur
so that you'll know what to look out for
in your own systems
then we'll talk a bit about who might be
affected by these harms
so in other words which groups of people
or subpopulations might be most at risk
next we'll run through where these harms
come from focusing on the different
stages of the machine learning pipeline
and at each stage of the pipeline we'll
talk about best practices and strategies
that you can use to mitigate the harms
that can arise
at that stage and then finally we'll
talk about some recently developed
software tools
before concluding with a handful of open
questions
and key takeaways
okay types of harm so i want to note
that the next few slides are based on a
framework for characterizing types of
harm
by aaron shapiro solomon baroccus kate
crawford
and myself though i've modified the
framework a little bit here
broadly speaking there are five main
types of harm
that can occur in a machine learning
system
allocation quality of service
stereotyping denigration
and overall under representation
to explain each of these five types i'm
going to run through some illustrative
examples
starting with the most well-known type
allocation
but before i do that i want to note that
these types are not mutually exclusive
it's possible for a single system to
exhibit
more than one type of harm and indeed
many of the examples that i'll show you
over the next few slides could
potentially illustrate
one or more of the other types as well
so first allocation as i said earlier
many of the recent stories in the media
have focused on high-stakes decisions
where machine learning systems are used
to allocate opportunities
resources or information in ways that
can have significant negative impacts
on people's lives so for example
amazon abandoned its automated hiring
system
after finding that the system amplified
gender bias
by withholding employment opportunities
from women in the tech industry
similarly the racial bias found in the
compass recidivism prediction tool
is also a harm of allocation because
among defendants who ultimately did not
reoffend
black defendants were much more likely
to be classified as
high risk than white defendants and thus
denied the opportunity of being released
on bail
quality of service is all about whether
a system
works as well for one person as it does
for another
even if no opportunities resources or
information
are extended or withheld so for example
last year
researchers found that three commercial
gender classifiers
had higher error rates for images of
darker skinned women
than for images of lighter skinned men
much like accessibility issues harms
relating to quality of service
also raise questions about respect
dignity and personhood
imagine how a user might feel if a
system repeatedly fails to recognize her
voice
but easily recognizes those of her peers
as a second example of a harm related to
quality of service
virtual reality systems often make women
feel sick
while men seem to be largely unaffected
okay stereotyping one of the most
well-known examples of stereotyping and
machine learning is the example i
mentioned
earlier where online ads were more
likely to suggest that people with black
sounding names
had been arrested thereby reinforcing
negative stereotypes of black
criminality
in a similar vein researchers at
princeton found that translating
he is a nurse and she is a doctor into
turkish a gender-neutral language
and then back into english yields the
stereotypical
she is a nurse and he is a doctor
and just to be clear this home was not
unique to google translate
it affected microsoft translator and
other machine learning systems too
and google actually came up with a
really creative way to address this harm
just last month
denigration is where a machine learning
system is itself
part of a process that is actively
derogatory and offensive
so for example a couple of years ago
google
photos infamously mislabeled an image of
a black woman
as gorillas this mislabeling is
offensive not just because the system
made a mistake
but because it specifically applied a
label that has a long history of being
purposefully
used to denigrate and to demean people
to liken them to animals
as another example of denigration
microsoft had to shut down the chatbot
tay
shortly after it launched because it
started generating hate speech
over and under representation are fairly
self-explanatory
but as a concrete example researchers at
the university of washington
found that professions with an equal or
higher percentage of men than women
for image search results were even more
heavily skewed
toward images of men than reality
so then to recap the five main types of
harm that can occur in a machine
learning system
are allocation quality of service
stereotyping denigration and overall
under representation
before i move on i want to again
reiterate that these types are not
mutually exclusive
a single machine learning system can
certainly exhibit
more than one type of harm as i've tried
to indicate here on this slide
all right great so we've covered
different types of harm
next i'm going to talk briefly about who
might be affected by these harms
so in other words which groups of people
or subpopulations
might be most at risk
in general the machine learning
literature typically focuses on
subpopulations that are protected by
law such as race gender age
or religion in practice though there are
many subpopulations that we might wish
to be fair with respect to
and it's not always easy to identify the
most relevant ones
last summer jen and i along with our
colleagues hal dalmae and mira dudik
and our incredible intern ken holstein
conducted the first systematic
investigation
of industry teams challenges and needs
for support
in developing fairer machine learning
systems will be
which will be published at this year's
conference on human factors in computing
systems
we found among other things that
practitioners expressed needs for
support
in identifying which subpopulations to
consider
when auditing their systems for biases
some practitioners also noted that the
most relevant subpopulations
may even be application specific
with permission i'll read you a quote
that illustrates this point
from a practitioner whose team develops
general purpose machine learning tools
people start thinking about sensitive
attributes like your ethnicity
your religion your sexuality your gender
but the biggest problem i found is that
these cohorts should be defined
based on the domain and problem for
example for automated rating evaluation
maybe it should be defined based on
whether the writer is a native speaker
it's also really important to consider
intersections of populations
the case of emma de graffenreid versus
general motors
is a really great example of why so in
emma and several other black women sued
general motors for discrimination
arguing that the company segregated its
workforce by race and gender
general motors pushed back claiming that
they hired black people
and they hired women however digging
further into the data
revealed that all the black people they
hired were men
who worked in warehouses while all the
women they hired
were white and worked as secretaries
so in other words only by considering
the intersection of racing gender
was it possible to show that general
motors was indeed discriminating against
black women
one obstacle to detecting and mitigating
harms
that affect particular subpopulations is
access to relevant attributes the
machine learning literature generally
assumes
access to these attributes at the level
of individuals
however many teams have no such access
and instead rely on course grained
partial or indirect information
one way around this is to ask users to
report relevant attributes
purely for the purpose of auditing
systems for biases
however this can raise privacy concerns
especially in light of the european
union's general data protection
regulation or gdpr
and some users may object
another option is to try to infer the
relevant attributes from other available
data sources
though this can introduce new biases and
again
users may object
sometimes the sub-populations that we
wish to be fair with respect to
are defined in terms of social
constructs
which makes accurately measuring
relative relevant
attributes especially hard
for example race is a social construct
one that depends on geography
context and even time moreover
two people can both identify as the same
race
but have very different physical
characteristics
therefore in the context of a computer
vision system
for example it may be preferable to
consider fairness with respect to skin
tone
an easily measurable attribute rather
than race
as well as being observable skin tone is
also more likely to affect the
performance of a computer vision system
than race per se
so before i move on i do want to note
that although this talk focuses on
fairness with respect to particular
subpopulations
this is not the only way to think about
fairness
for example some machine learning papers
focus instead on
individual fairness or treating similar
people
similarly and while this is intuitively
appealing
this approach generally requires the
ability to define
some quantitative notion of similarity
between
individuals in practice though this can
be challenging to do
accurately so we're not going to cover
individual fairness here today
another way to think about fairness is
in terms of counter factuals
so for example would i have been hired
if everything about me were the same
except for my gender again
this approach to fairness is intuitively
appealing
but as isa cola houseman points out it's
not possible to manipulate
to manipulate race or gender in this way
even putting aside practicalities you
can't just
flip someone's gender and assume that
nothing else about them would change
for example my personality and
characteristics
are all heavily influenced by my lived
experiences as a
woman and so it's just not realistic to
expect
that i would possess the same
personality and characteristics
if i had instead been born a man
so for this reason we're also not going
to cover counterfactual fairness today
great so with that i'm going to hand
over to jen for the next part of this
talk
all right okay
so hello i'm jen wartman vaughn
in the last few minutes hannah's walked
us through different types of harm that
can arise in machine learning systems
and which groups of people are most
likely to be at risk from these harms
so i am now going to spend the next
chunk of time discussing
where these harms come from and at the
same time
strategies that you can take to mitigate
these harms
i want to emphasize from the very start
of this portion of the talk
that fairness is not something that can
be treated as an afterthought
and it needs to be considered throughout
the entire machine learning pipeline
if you walk away from this part of our
talk remembering one thing
i hope it's that
so a typical machine learning pipeline
looks something like this
we start by defining the task or problem
that would like to solve
we next construct a data set data set
construction
involves selecting a data source
acquiring the data
pre-processing the data and perhaps
labeling the data
third we define a model are we going to
use a linear model or a decision tree or
a neural network
what is our objective function each of
these choices is associated with its own
set of implicit assumptions
fourth we train the model on our data
we next test and validate the model
before deploying the model
in the wild and finally we gather
feedback about the performance of our
model in practice and use this feedback
to improve the system
we'll see that decisions that are made
at every point in this pipeline can
introduce bias
so let's start at the beginning with the
task definition itself
what is the problem that you are trying
to use machine learning to solve
so as one extreme example of what can go
wrong here
in 2016 a research paper came out by a
group in
china who were training a face
recognition system to predict
who is going to commit a crime based on
images of people's faces
this is extremely concerning for a whole
suite of reasons and could lead to
substantial harms for people who are
misclassified
i hope it goes without saying that this
is a questionable and rather sketchy
task design
and i would argue that this is not a
task that machine learning should be
used for
period
but there are more subtle examples too
consider the problem of gender
classification predicting someone's
gender from a photo
on the surface it might be less clear
what are the potential harms here
but there are a couple of potential
issues that come up so one
is that a gender classifier would
generally only predict
binary gender so it won't work at all
for people whose gender is non-binary
gender classifiers also reinforce
societal stereotypes about how men and
women are supposed to look
in fact the way that a system like this
would probably work is actually by
exploiting these very stereotypes
it will therefore only work well for
people who look like typical men or
typical women
finally it's often best not to force a
gender label on somebody without asking
them themselves
in the first place
there are steps that we can take to
mitigate harms during the task
definition stage of the pipeline
first clearly define your task and the
model's intended effects
taking gender classification as an
example the task here is to classify
people as male or female using images of
their faces
the intended effect is for people who
look male to be classified as male and
people who look female to be classified
as female
two try to identify any unintended
effects or biases
you may need to do some reading here are
there known biases for this particular
task or domain
for gender classification one unintended
effect could be
that people who don't look like gender
norms could be misclassified
when thinking about unintent intended
effects and biases
think about how others might take the
output of your system
and use this and you know what systems
your output may be feeding into
three make sure to involve diverse
stakeholders and multiple perspectives
to try to uncover
unknown unknowns and blind spots in your
system
in our example involving diverse
stakeholders might reveal that
non-binary people are underrepresented
and will likely suffer from poor quality
of service here
next be willing to redefine the task if
you need to
or even willing to abort in extreme
cases
in our example you might first consider
adding additional labels beyond
male and female but through
conversations with diverse stakeholders
you may realize that the system actually
relies on stereotyping at its very core
if misclassifications are too costly you
may decide to just give up on the
project
finally if you do decide to proceed
document any unintended effects
and biases so that you can keep
referring back to them
and checking for them throughout the
rest of your development process
sometimes task definitions change and
evolve over time
and biases can end up being reintroduced
later in the pipeline
okay let's move on to data set
construction
so i'm going to spend a bit more time on
this phase of the pipeline than the
others because it's very common for
biases to creep in here
and there are a bunch of different ways
that this can happen
so one way that this can happen is that
the data source may reflect societal
biases
the world has a lot of bias in it and
our data sets usually reflect the world
this is what happened when amazon tried
to build the machine learning based
recruiting tool
if your data source contains mostly male
resumes and you've historically hired
mostly men your machine learning system
is going to pick up on this
linguistic bias is also a problem people
are more likely to say
she is a nurse than he is a nurse so as
hannah discussed before
a translation system trained on text or
speech that's generated by
people is going to prefer that
translation
bias can also arise if data is collected
from a skewed source
so if we train a face recognition system
on images of mostly white men
then it will likely work well for white
men but maybe less well on other
populations
as another example the city of boston
released a smartphone app called street
bump in 2011.
the app would monitor for bumpiness
caused by potholes when people were
driving down the street
and report these potholes to the city so
that they could then be repaired
on the surface this seems like a really
great idea
the problem was that back in 2011
smartphones were much less prevalent
than they are today and so the people
who use the app
tended to be younger and more affluent
as a result the potholes that were
reported were much more likely to come
from wealthy neighborhoods
luckily the city did eventually become
aware of this problem and quickly acted
to counteract it
skewed samples can also arise due to the
backgrounds and cultural biases of the
people involved in the data collection
process
for example during the interviews that
we conducted with machine learning
practitioners which hannah mentioned
earlier
one team reported that they had trouble
collecting images of celebrities that
were popular in other countries simply
because
nobody on their team happened to know
what these celebrities look like
so in order to mitigate harms that arise
when selecting your data source
you should think critically about
potential biases before
actually collecting any data check for
biases in the data source selection
process
before building their recruiting system
amazon could have carefully considered
their data source and
realized that it was problematic since
there are fewer women in tech jobs and
the data would be heavily skewed male
try to identify societal biases that are
present in your data source
we know that there are more female
nurses than male nurses
and the people are likely to talk about
nurses in a gender stereotyped way
so this is a bias that again could be
identified in advance
fourth check for biases in the cultural
context of the data source
and finally you should check that the
data source matches your expected
deployment context
and this is something that i'll come
back to again a little bit later
in terms of the process of actually
collecting your data once you've
identified your source
you should check for biases in the
technology used to collect the data
thinking through potential biases in the
technology could have more quickly
identified problems with the use of the
street bump app
check for biases in the humans involved
in the data collection process
this can catch cases where a team
doesn't have the proper
cultural background to gather the data
that they need for some system
next if sampling data points from a
large population
check for biases in the sampling
strategy and assure sufficient
representation of subpopulations
following these two best practices would
have flagged the skewed data sets that
many face recognition and gender
classification systems were being
trained on
finally check that the data collection
process itself
is fair and ethical this one can be
tricky
even if we know that we need more data
from a certain subpopulation there's
this question of how we can actually
ethically collect it
the challenge is to avoid putting a tax
on already disadvantaged populations for
example by
forcing all of our co-workers who are
from some minority population to come
and supply data for us on every
product that we're building
yet another way that bias can arise in
data set construction is through
labeling and pre-processing
for example there's a lot of research
out there showing that human biases come
into play when people are grading
essays but some states are still using
automated essay grading systems where
the training data consists of essays
graded by humans
this is essentially treating the human
scores as ground truth when we know that
they're not ground truth
once again there are best practices that
can be followed in this data labeling
and pre-processing stage
so first you should check whether you're
introducing biases by discarding data
for example suppose your data points
contain gender what might happen if you
just throw away data from anyone who
declines to report their gender
relatedly you could be introducing
biases by bucketing values for example
if you're bucketing by race
not everyone identifies with only a
single race
third you should check whether any
software that you're using for
pre-processing might introduce biases
for example you may want to run machine
translation on text as a pre-processing
step
but we've already seen that machine
translation systems can do things like
swap the gender of pronouns
similarly you should check any labeling
or annotation software for biases
and finally you should consider whether
um the human labelers
who are in the loop here might introduce
bias as what in the case with the
automated essay grading
many of these data related strategies
can be at least partially addressed with
better
data related standards and documentation
this isn't a new idea so other
industries have been in exactly this
place before
including the automobile industry and
the electronics industry
these days in fact every electronic
component ranging from the simplest
resistor
all the way up to the most complex
microprocessor has a corresponding
data sheet detailing all of its
operating characteristics recommended
usage and other information
inspired by data sheets for electronic
components hannah and i along with some
of our amazing collaborators
have a project called data sheets for
data sets we propose that
every data set model or pre-trained api
should be accompanied by a data sheet
that documents its creation
intended uses limitations maintenance
legal and ethical considerations and so
on
we view this as a way to surface
potential biases making it easier for
teams
to develop more fair machine learning
systems though it has benefits that go
far beyond fairness too
this is a prototype of a data sheet that
we made for label faces in the wild a
well-known computer vision data set
consisting of images of faces it's hard
to see from the slide
but the data sheet contains a variety of
information about the data set
including a breakdown of images by age
gender and so on
to help teams construct data sheets for
their own data sets we've put together
an initial set of questions that cover
different types of information
that we think belong in a data sheet the
questions are divided into seven
categories listed here some motivation
data set composition
the collection process um data
pre-processing distribution maintenance
and legal and ethical concerns
and each of these categories has about
five to ten questions
for example in the composition category
there are questions about the data
points themselves
as well as questions about recommended
data splits and evaluation metrics
in the collection process category we
have questions about
um who is involved in the collection
process the time frame over which the
data was collected and whether the data
is sampled from some larger population
the data sheets concept has been pretty
well received so far but of course
in order to turn it into a standard
engineering practice
there are a number of implementation
changes challenges that have to be
addressed
i won't go into details here but we and
others throughout microsoft are
currently working on addressing these
challenges and refining this concept for
wider use
okay so that's enough about data set
construction
let's move on to model definition so
what is a model
well a model is just a mathematical
abstraction
of some part of the world for example
we might assume that the price of a
house is a linear function of the number
of bedrooms the number of bathrooms the
number of square feet
with a little bit of random noise and
variation added
by its very nature a model is simpler
than the world
so choosing a model necessarily means
making some assumptions
what should be included in the model and
what shouldn't how should we include the
things that we do decide to include
and sometimes these assumptions can
privilege some people over others
consider predictive policing a
predictive policing system may make
predictions
about where crimes will be committed
based on historic arrest data
one implicit assumption here is that the
number of arrests that are made in a
location
is an accurate proxy for the amount of
crime in that location
this doesn't take into account that
policing practices can be racially
biased
or that there may be historic over
policing in less affluent neighborhoods
as another example it's common for
teachers to be evaluated based on
factors including their students test
scores
as highlighted in a federal lawsuit this
assumes that students test scores are an
accurate predictor of teacher quality
but of course this is not always the
case and a good teacher should do more
than just test prep
are also implicit assumptions in the
structure of the model chosen
so in this toy example in which
individuals are represented by
two features we've got a majority
population and a minority population
that look fundamentally different from
each other in terms of these two
features that we've chosen
in this case there's no simple linear
classifier that would work well for both
this means that you probably don't want
to be using a simple linear classifier
on these features
maybe a non-linear model would be a
better choice in this situation
or maybe we should just be looking for a
different set of features altogether
finally harms can be introduced by
assumptions that go into the objective
function
here i'm showing bing image search
results for the term boy on the left
and the term girl on the right these
clearly look very different from each
other
this probably comes from the fact that
bing like all search engines
is optimizing for clicks among other
things
this example shows just how hard it can
be to fix fairness issues
in different circumstances the word girl
may be referring to a child
or a woman and users search for this
term with different
intentions right so in this case for
reasons you can imagine one of these
attention
intentions may be more prevalent than
the other
so when defining a model we should
follow these best practices
first clearly define all of our
assumptions about the model
second try to identify any biases that
are present in these assumptions
the ability to use number of arrests as
a proxy for amount of crime is an
assumption and should be questioned
third check whether the model structure
introduces biases
next check the objective function for
any unintended effects
we're making an assumption when we
design a search engine or a website to
optimize clicks
and assumptions like these should be
questioned in the context of whether
they might introduce biases
you might also consider including some
notion of fairness directly in the
objective function
if this is something that it's
appropriate to do in your setting
okay let's move on to the training
process
so the training process is the stage of
the pipeline where we optimize or learn
the parameters of a model
the weights w1 w2 and w3 in this example
that i showed earlier
based on the training data that you have
in your objective
so there's some good news here
once you've settled on your data set
your model and your objective
the actual training algorithm that you
use is probably not going to introduce
any additional bias
we see this as a common misconception
actually you generally don't have
a biased algorithm at least not a bias
training algorithm
the problem usually comes more directly
from the model you've chosen or the
objective
or these other factors that we've
discussed
okay so the testing phase of the
pipeline is your opportunity to check
for biases and potential harms
and problems can arise if you don't have
the right testing data
or the right metrics in mind
for example let's return to this
research paper that showed that
commercial
gender classification software performed
poorly on women with dark skin
this is the kind of problem that can be
caught during the testing phase
if you want to build products that work
well for everyone
then you should explicitly be testing
products performance on different
segments of the population
in the case of the compass recidivism
prediction tool
there was some internal testing but
external audits still
revealed unfairness in this system so to
talk about why
we need to get a little bit into metrics
i'm going to spend just a couple of
minutes going through some different
metrics here just to give you an
overview of what the landscape looks
like
fairness metrics are currently most
well-defined for classification problems
to simplify things i'm going to focus
only on binary classification in my
discussion here
and the main thing that i want you to
take away from this is that there are a
bunch of fairness metrics and these
metrics are more or less appropriate in
different circumstances
if you want to learn more there's a
great tutorial by arvin narayanan from
fat star 2018 that you can find online
okay so to define the fairness metrics
that are typically considered for binary
classification
it's useful to start with the idea of a
confusion matrix which many people might
already be familiar with
here i'm showing a confusion matrix for
a hiring scenario
we have some applicants who are
qualified for a job and some applicants
who are unqualified
our machine learning algorithm chooses
to hire some of these applicants and to
reject
others qualified applicants who are
hired are true positives while
unqualified applicants who are rejected
are true negatives your algorithm is
getting both of these right
meanwhile qualified applicants who are
rejected are false negatives and
unqualified applicants who are hired are
false positives
the confusion matrix simply tells us how
many applicants
fall into each of these four buckets and
these four numbers that are given by a
confusion matrix can be used to compute
various standard machine learning
performance metrics
like accuracy and precision so rather
than considering only a single confusion
matrix for a whole set of applicants we
can choose to break things down by
demographic
and compute separate confusion matrices
for say our male applicants and our
female applicants
to be concrete we filled in one example
of what these matrices might look like
with some numbers here
notice that in this example there are
100 men and 100 women
in total for both men and women the
system makes correct decisions
on 75 out of 100 applicants
60 qualified men are hired and 15
unqualified men are rejected
these are all correct decisions
meanwhile 15 qualified women are hired
and 60 unqualified women are rejected
also correct decisions
so the accuracy is the same in both of
these cases but the system makes
different types of errors on these two
groups
so let's see how a few different
fairness metrics play out in this case
so the first fairness metric that you
might hear about is demographic parity
demographic parody is based only on
classifier output
and doesn't take into account true
labels at all
it says that applicants should have
about the same probability of being
hired regardless of whether they're male
or female so the ratio of
hired applicants to total applicants
should be the same for each group or at
least approximately the same for each
group
if you happen to have heard of the eeocs
80 20 disparate impact rule
this is a very similar idea
so in this case the system does not
satisfy demographic parity
because 80 of 100 men are hired while 20
of 100 women are hired
but you know maybe you might say this is
okay because in this particular example
more of the men are qualified than the
women
um just as an aside demographic parity
is perhaps the first metric that you
would want to look at
when evaluating an automated hiring
system like the one that amazon proposed
so going a bit deeper predictive parity
takes the true label into account as
well as the classifier output
it looks at the probability that an
applicant from some group is qualified
given that you've chosen to hire this
applicant
and it says that this should be the same
or about the same for both of these
groups
in this case the system does satisfy
predictive parity
since for both of these groups
three-quarters of
hired applicants are qualified
now false positive rate balance is
another metric that says that false
positive rates should be the same for
both groups
that is the probability that an
unqualified applicant is hired
must be the same or about the same for
men as it is for women
in other words your classifier should
treat all unqualified applicants
the same regardless of whether they're
male or female
in our example the false positive rates
are different
with a substantially larger fraction of
unqualified men
being higher than unqualified women
false negative rate balance is
essentially the same thing but for false
negative rates
it says that the probability of a
qualified applicant being rejected
should be roughly the same as for men as
it is for women
in other words the classifier should
treat all qualified applicants the same
regardless of whether they're male or
female
again in this example our false negative
rates are different with qualified
female candidates much less likely to be
higher
than qualified male candidates you may
sometimes hear the term
equalized odds come up and in the
context of binary classification
this simply means that you
simultaneously satisfy false positive
rate balance and false negative rate
balance
basically treating all similarly
qualified candidates similarly
so this notion of equalized odds that i
just mentioned is effectively the
fairness metric the propublica
considered when it was auditing the
compass system for racial bias
in other words they asked whether
compass makes similar errors
in terms of both type of error and
quantity of error
for black and white defendants and
indeed they found that it does not
because of this they said that the
system was racially biased
in response northpoint the company that
built compass
argued that compass does satisfy
predictive parity
and is therefore fair but it's
so there's a lot of back and forth about
this and about why the system couldn't
just satisfy
all of these metrics but it turns out
that things are not so easy
in fact it turns out that it's
mathematically impossible
for a system to simultaneously satisfy
predictive parity
false positive rate balance and false
negative rebalance
any system that satisfies two of these
properties must necessarily fail to
satisfy the third
this impossibility theorem was really at
the heart of the public debates
around compass and rachel bias as long
as north point
requires the compass satisfy predictive
parity it can never
satisfy equalized odds so what should
northpoint
do in this situation well this is a
tough question
but people have made the argument that
given the impact of these decisions
on people's lives equalizing false
positives
and false negative rates between races
is
more important perhaps than calibration
so
equalize odds is arguably a better
measure here
okay so what are some best practices for
testing
first you should ensure that the test
data set matches the context
in which the system is expected to be
deployed and ensure that the test data
has sufficient representation in it
doing these things would have helped
developers identify
the performance imbalance and gender
classification systems before these
systems were ever deployed in the first
case um of course all the standard risks
of overfitting apply here
so i just want to mention you should be
aware of this if you find yourself
really relying on one particular test
data set and tuning your model to be
fair on one particular test data set
next you should involve diverse
stakeholders who represent multiple
perspectives
to ensure that you're testing for the
right things
the diverse voices project from the tech
policy lab at uw has created
guidelines for making tech policy more
inclusive
by having short targeted conversations
with panels of people who have diverse
viewpoints
similar ideas could easily be used in
product development as well
additionally you should clearly state
all of the fairness requirements for
your system
and use appropriate metrics to ensure
that your requirements are met
but of course you should keep in mind
here that there are trade-offs that need
to be made with any of these metrics
and that again many aspects of fairness
are just not possible to capture with
metrics
at all as hannah mentioned before
fairness is a socio-technical
concept and we can't always use
quantifiable metrics to capture it
okay so moving on to deployment the most
common issue here
is the one that i mentioned briefly a
few minutes ago
that the deployment population is
somehow different from the population
that you either
implicitly or explicitly assumed that
you would have
that is your deployment population is
different from the population from which
your training and testing data were
generated
or the population that you had in mind
when you were defining your model
a common example is collecting training
data from people in one country
say the us and then deploying a system
in other parts of the world
there's actually some interesting
research way back in 2011
they looked at available face
recognition tools and showed that the
location where a face recognition system
was developed had significant impacts on
its performance on different populations
specifically systems were substantially
more accurate on faces from the same
geographical region
that the system was developed in
when deploying a system you should
double check that the data source
matches the deployment context
and keep an eye out for discrepancies as
you collect
more data on your system's performance
you should also monitor your fairness
metrics for any unexpected changes
at this point in the pipeline it can
also be advantageous to invite diverse
stakeholders to audit your system for
potential biases
for the initial audits it's really
better to be in control of this process
yourself
you don't want to be in a situation
where someone from the outside
audits your product for fairness before
you get a chance to
remember it was external audits that
revealed that commercial gender
classification software
had different performance on different
groups
finally you should monitor user reports
for any potential fairness issues
all right so finally there's the
feedback stage
this is something that's discussed a lot
in the context of predictive policing
and hot spots
so as we've already discussed predictive
policing systems
operate under this assumption that more
rest in an area means more crime
this can create a feedback loop or a
self-fulfilling prophecy
more officers are deployed to
neighborhoods where more
crime is predicted and this ends up
leading to more arrests which leads to
higher crime being predicted in the
future and to even more officers being
deployed to these areas
adversarial feedback can also be an
issue here
a few years ago when microsoft released
the social chatbot tay
there are groups who took advantage of
tay's use of feedback
in order to adversarially insert biases
and other harms into the system
the best practices here at the feedback
stage overlap
heavily with those for the deployment
stage which makes sense because the line
between these stages can be pretty fuzzy
you should continue to monitor the match
between your training data and the data
that you're seeing in the wild
continue to monitor fairness metrics and
continue to monitor user reports too
monitoring appropriate fairness metrics
could surface that predictive policing
systems are getting more biased over
time
you should also monitor users
interactions with your system
and if necessary you might consider
prohibiting some types of interaction
altogether
for example for a chatbot like tay in
addition to
monitoring things it may be necessary to
actually restrict certain types of
feedback
especially because in this case the
severity of the harms that can arise
is high
all right so we have made it through the
machine learning pipeline
we've talked about both where harms come
from and strategies that you can take to
mitigate these harms and with that i'm
going to turn things back over to hannah
all right so for the last part of this
talk i'm going to tell you about some
recently developed software tools for
detecting and mitigating harms
over the past few years the academic
machine learning community has turned
its attention to the topic of fairness
and machine learning
and while this graph here isn't strictly
accurate
over the past few years we've seen a
massive increase in the number of papers
published on this topic
spurred by this increase we've also seen
researchers and practitioners
start to develop software tools that
implement the ideas put forward in these
papers
so i want to run through a handful of
these tools with you
just so that they're on your radar
okay so the tools i want to tell you
about fall into a couple of different
categories
the first category is auditing both
auditing data sets to uncover potential
biases
and auditing the outputs of systems to
see if those outputs are fair
according to the kinds of metrics that
jen told you about
earlier the first tool i want to
highlight is equitass
which was developed by researchers at
the university of chicago's center for
data science and public policy
equitas consists of a web audit tool a
python library and a command line tool
for auditing the outputs of systems
for allocating opportunities resources
or information
according to some of the metrics that
jen told you about previously
plus a couple of other metrics as well
it's pretty easy to use and generates
really nice bias reports
that is a little limited in what it can
do
the second auditing tool that should be
on your radar is ibm's ai
fairness 360. this tool was recently
released
and received a lot of attention in the
media
like equitas it's focused specifically
on systems for allocating opportunities
resources or information and it does
implement more
fairness metrics than equitas though
it's not entirely clear how commonly
used
some of these other metrics are one nice
thing which i haven't played around with
yet
is that it implements some metrics for
assessing individual fairness
unlike equitas
before i move on to the next category of
tools i do want to again
emphasize that fairness is a
fundamentally socio-technical
challenge so these tools are not be-all
and end-all solutions
and are only appropriate in certain
particularly limited circumstances
specifically they focus on harms of
allocation
and certain types of quality of service
and not on other types of harm
moreover there are many aspects of
fairness such as
justice and due process and so on and so
forth
that aren't captured by metrics that
look only at parity
in decision making and finally as jen
told you
it's impossible to simultaneously
satisfy
all of these fairness metrics except in
very rare circumstances
which means that if you try to improve
your system with respect to one metric
you might make it worse with respect to
another
as a result it's important to discuss
which metrics are most important to
prioritize
in a given context to discuss the
limitations of those metrics
and then to make trade-offs and to
examine the impact
of those those trade-offs but these
tools do at least
give you a way to explore these various
different
options great
so the second category of tools that i
want to tell you about
is fair classification so tools for
developing
fair systems for allocating
opportunities resources or
information by specifically making
decisions of the form
loan no loan hire don't hire
bail no bail and so on
there's been a lot of research in this
space focusing on pre-processing
data post-processing system outputs
uh and all involving some notion of
fairness sometimes this notion of
fairness is even included
in the classifier's objective function
i'm not going to talk about all of these
today but instead i'm going to focus on
one method that i developed recently
with some collaborators
so this method takes the approach of
including some notion of fairness
in the classifier's objective function
and the typical way to do this
is to typically to first choose an
appropriate fairness metric
then the machine learning goal becomes
one of maximizing classifier accuracy
while minimizing unfairness according to
the chosen metric
so in other words the classifier's
objective function
has two parts classifier accuracy
and the chosen fairness metric there are
two
technical challenges to this goal first
choosing the fairness metric and two
learning an
accurate classifier subject to the
constraints imposed by that metric
our method focuses specifically on the
second one of these challenges
we've shown what we've done is we've
shown that for a wide range of fairness
metrics
famous constrained classification can be
reduced
to cost-sensitive classification a
well-studied class of problems
for which there are many off-the-shelf
tools
there are several benefits to this
approach first
our method works with many different
fairness metrics
and this means that there's no need to
start again from first principles
to switch to a different metric second
our method is agnostic to the form of
the classifier and the training
algorithm
as a result it works with a wide range
of existing classification methods
such as neural networks trained with
backprop ridge regression solved in
closed form
or support vector machines trained with
stochastic gradient descent
taken together these two points mean
that our work kind of puts a stop to
this cottage industry of papers
that each consider a single
classification method
and a single fairness metric
another benefit of our method is that it
doesn't require
deployment time access to attributes
like race or gender
and this is great for two reasons one as
i explained earlier many teams have no
such access
to individual level attributes and two
this is likely important for mitigating
disparate treatment concerns
finally unlike other approaches to fair
classification
our method is theoretically guaranteed
to find the most accurate classifier
subject to the chosen fairness metric
we've also empirically demonstrated this
last benefit
using a variety of data sets from
education
employment and criminal justice showing
that we achieve
better accuracy furnace trade-offs than
other fair classification
approaches and we've released an open
source
python library that implements our
method
while i'm talking about this i do want
to point out that ibm's ai
fairness 360 also implements three
methods for fair classification
though the method i just told you about
is more general and more flexible
than any of these three methods
before i move on i want to highlight
some points to consider when thinking
about fair classification
first you need to choose an appropriate
fairness metric
of course because there are trade-offs
between metrics
it's still important to assess other
fairness metrics
in order to examine the impact of these
trade-offs
second people myself included often talk
about the
accuracy fairness trade-off implying
that by prioritizing
fairness as well as accuracy you might
end up with a less accurate classifier
this may be true with respect to some
test data set
but it's important to think about your
deployment context as jen mentioned
which may be different to your test data
in particular you may actually end up
with better accuracy at deployment time
by including fairness in your
classifier's objective function
you can kind of think about this as a
form of regularization
finally i want to again note that there
are many aspects of fairness
that aren't captured by these kinds of
metrics
and that there are many types of harm
that can arise in context
other than classification
next i want to talk briefly about
mitigating stereotypes in word
embeddings
so earlier i told you that researchers
at princeton found that translating he
is a nurse
and she is a doctor into turkish a
gender-neutral language
and then back into english yields the
stereotypical
she is a nurse and he is a doctor
jen then told you that this harm likely
occurred because of societal biases
that are present in the text data used
to train machine translation systems
more specifically many translation
systems rely on
word embeddings generated by embedding
methods such as word to vec
which embeds words into a low
dimensional space
based on their surrounding words in a
corpus of documents
our colleague adam collie and his
collaborators
showed the word to vac when trained on
news articles
exhibits strong male female gender
stereotypes
for example man is close to programmer
while woman is close to homemaker
these stereotypes are then propagated to
any downstream
systems such as translation systems that
use embeddings adam and his
collaborators
also showed that you can in some
circumstances
remove such stereotypes by identifying a
definitional dimension
and an orthogonal stereotypical
dimension
in the low dimensional space and then
projecting
words embeddings down so as to eliminate
the stereotypical dimension
they also released an open source python
library that implements this
so there are a handful of points to
consider though when thinking about
using tools for mitigating stereotypes
in word embeddings
first this approach works with
pre-trained word embeddings
so you don't have to train your own word
embeddings to use it
that said it is harder to integrate into
systems that simultaneously learn
embeddings
at the same time as performing some
downstream tasks
not all subpopulations have an obvious
definitional dimension
which means that it's harder to remove
some kinds of stereotypes than others
in part because of this and in part
because stereotypes relate to a broad
cultural context it's impossible to
guarantee
that you have removed all possible
biases
and finally it's really important to
assess the effects of mitigating
stereotypes
on the performance of any downstream
systems that use the embeddings
great so we did it we covered all four
topics
and hopefully we've now given you a
fairly comprehensive overview
of fairness in machine learning
before we conclude though i do want to
briefly talk about open
questions as we've emphasized throughout
this talk
fairness is a fundamentally societal
concept
and one that is still pretty new to the
tech in
industry as a result there are a lot of
open questions and not a lot of easy
answers
i therefore want to briefly note some of
the open questions that i think are
particularly important
just so that you're aware of them when
you're thinking about this stuff
so i mentioned earlier that jen and i
along with our colleagues hal dalmei
and mira dudek as well as our awesome
intern ken holstein
spent last summer conducting the first
systematic investigation
of industry teams challenges and needs
for support
in developing fairer machine learning
systems
i want to very briefly tell you about
some of our main findings
because they i think they illustrate
some of the most pressing
open questions just so you know where
these findings came from
to conduct our study we followed
established methodology
from human computer interaction
specifically
we started by conducting a series of
initial semi-structured
interviews with six product managers
each responsible for a
product in a different domain
based on the themes that emerged from
these initial interviews
we then conducted a second round of
interviews with another 29 practitioners
and in total we ended up interviewing 35
people
from 25 different teams across 10 major
technology companies
and as you can see from this slide these
teams span a variety of domains
from adaptive tutoring to multimodal
sensing
to web search where possible we tried to
interview
multiple people from the same team in
order to hear different perspectives
on the team's challenges and needs for
support
in addition to our semi-structured
interviews we also conducted an
anonymous survey
of 267 industry practitioners
working in domains ranging from robotics
and cyber physical systems
to natural language processing in roles
such as social scientist
data labeler program manager researcher
and data scientist
we found that a number of themes emerged
from our semi-structured interviews
which were then
further reinforced by the data from our
anonymous survey
i'm not going to talk through these in
detail but i want to highlight some of
the needs for support
first we found needs for support in
auditing systems for biases in a
diverse range of applications beyond
allocation classification and prediction
we also found needs for support in
creating fairer data sets
so how best to do this in practice
we found needs for support in
identifying relevant
subpopulations as i mentioned earlier
and we found needs for support in
detecting biases
with access only to coarse grain partial
or
indirect information and i think these
needs highlight
some of the open questions in this area
that we really
as a community need to start thinking
about addressing
all right so to wrap up i want to end
with some key
takeaways i'm going to structure these
takeaways around
three calls to action these calls aren't
comprehensive
but they do highlight some of the most
important dimensions to keep
in mind when thinking about fairness
first prioritize fairness at every stage
of the machine learning pipeline
fairness really should be a first order
priority
just like security and privacy but in
order to make this happen we can't treat
fairness
as an afterthought rather we have to
actively think about it starting
right from the task definition all the
way to deployment and feedback
second involve diverse stakeholders and
multiple perspectives
fairness and machine learning is a
fundamentally socio-technical challenge
that can't be addressed by computer
scientists or developers
alone we have to involve social
scientists
lawyers policy makers diverse teams
end users and all kinds of other
stakeholders
in these conversations to make sure that
we're answering the right questions
and finally adopt a growth mindset and
learn from failures
it's just not possible to solve fairness
we can't de-bias our models or our data
sets
or guarantee that they're bias free and
technology is just
never neutral fairness isn't a one-shot
process
either we will make mistakes let's
therefore anticipate them as best we can
embrace them and turn them into
something positive
that is learn from them and let them
contribute to our successes
thank you
okay hi everybody so this is jen wartman
vaughn and i am sitting here
live um in our office in new york with
hannah wallach
hey everyone so first we want to thank
everybody who's out there watching and
submitting their questions for our live
q a
and we're going to spend the next few
minutes answering some of these
questions
from the audience okay so
let me just kick things off with the
following question
isn't fairness and bias and machine
learning also about the coders
that develop a machine learning system
that's a good question and yes
absolutely throughout the talk we've
emphasized that decisions made at
every stage of the machine learning
pipeline affect the fairness of the
system and these decisions are often
made by the people who are building the
system
so this is why it's important to educate
the people involved about these topics
and the challenges they'll face along
the way we also said several times that
it's important to
involve diverse stakeholders in the
development process
one type of stakeholder is the people
who are developing the system
if you hire a more diverse team then
this team can help spot potential issues
before they make their way
into systems and products yeah so i
totally agree with all that
and that's actually a great segue into
one of the other questions we've
received
so if fairness is really a
socio-technical problem
what's the role of computer scientist
this is an awesome question
okay so machine learning systems are
just such a
huge part of our lives nowadays
influencing
absolutely everything from what we buy
to who we go on dates with
to who is invited to interview for jobs
and so on and so forth
so as a result these systems aren't just
kind of a
passive part of society rather than
actively participating
in shaping society so their
recommendations
decisions and other outputs affect the
world that we'll live in
tomorrow so because of this everyone
who's playing a role
in developing or deploying these systems
needs to think deeply about their
societal
impact and as jen just said it's really
important to involve
diverse stakeholders of all sorts in the
ai life cycle in the machine
learning pipeline but it's also
important that computer scientists
don't shift the responsibility of making
sure
that the systems that they develop are
fair
it's really easy for us as computer
scientists to downplay the societal
impact
of seemingly innocuous technical
decisions but these decisions can
ultimately have
a major influence on people's lives
so we need to make sure that we don't do
this we don't downplay the role of these
decisions we're making
and we also need to acknowledge the full
societal impacts of these decisions
while we're that we make while we're
developing and deploying our system
okay great uh so let me take another
question
uh so i'm excited about making the
products i build more
fair how do i convince my management
chain that it's important
we actually get this question a lot so
in addition to the technical challenges
around machine learning
there are also a lot of organizational
challenges
including convincing managers and senior
leadership that fairness is something
that should be prioritized and rewarded
in a company
of course it would be nice if everybody
just cared about fairness
just because it's the right thing to do
but when this is not the case
there are also some business motivations
for caring too
honestly avoiding bad pr can be a really
good motivator
we've all seen instances of bad pr
around fairness and bias
but in addition to that there's an
argument that everyone is better off
when a company builds more inclusive
products that work well for everyone
since more people will then want to buy
the products if they work well
great all right so i'll take the next
one
um how do you decide when to build a
system
versus when not to build okay
so this is a great question and honestly
i think this is one of the most
underlooked issues in the entire
discussion around
fairness in the machine learning
community
so we want to refer back to my answer
to one of the earlier questions where it
says that machine learning systems play
an
active role in shaping the society that
we live in
so one of the most important decisions
to make before developing any system
is should this system exist
unfortunately though there aren't any
easy answers to that question
and or even in how to make these kinds
of decisions
that's a really complicated question
that requires input and discussion with
a really wide range of stakeholders
that said one thing that i recommend
doing when trying to decide whether or
not to develop a system
is to ask the question who will this
system give
power to and who will it take power away
from oftentimes they seem that the
answers to this question
are really revealing and then end up
helping to guide the subsequent
discussion
about whether or not to build that
system and the other thing i want to
note is that there's a
paper called when the implication is not
to design
technology by eric obama and m6
silverman which actually digs pretty
deeply into this
issue by presenting a series of
questions that can help
researchers designers and practitioners
articulate a particular technology's
appropriateness
great thanks uh so i think i'm going to
paraphrase this question a bit
so how can we build fair products at a
small company with limited resources
and talent this is another great
question
so there are a lot of extra challenges
that come up in small companies since
employees tend to be stretched
pretty thin as it is and employees may
not have a lot of time to
think about anything that's not
considered critical to getting their
products
shipped on time that said
in some ways i'd argue that small
companies are actually at an advantage
because they don't have the burden of
trying to retroactively
fix giant existing systems with years
and years of
ugly legacy code instead if you're at a
small company and you're starting fresh
you have the opportunity to think about
fairness from the very
start of the development process
all right so i'll take this one here how
can machine learning improve
public policy i love this question
that's awesome
um one of the invited speakers at this
year's
eurips conference neural information
processing systems conference
was ed felton from princeton who spoke
about
machine learning needs public policy his
talk on this topic was absolutely
fantastic
and covered this question really in
quite a lot of detail
so rather than address it ourselves i
think we definitely recommend
checking out the recording which is
linked from the new rips website as it
does a really fantastic job of answering
it
great and i just wanted a second that um
ed's talk was really fantastic and i
think that
we absolutely should be trying to
influence policy
um okay so i think that we've got
time for one more question um and this
is a good one so
what are the big problems that the
research community
should be focusing on well we are very
glad that you asked that
uh first off let me emphasize that we
don't believe that there's any
short list of open computer science
problems that are somehow going to
solve fairness if we're able to solve
these problems
what we've learned through our
experience at microsoft and through our
own research
is that many of the most pressing
challenges out there
are really domain specific and sometimes
context specific
too and a lot of these challenges aren't
even computer science problems but
instead
fall under organizational science or
sps science and technology studies or
their psychology problems or
you know problems in all different
fields that said we do
think that practitioners are currently
under-supported
in terms of their ability to follow all
of the best practices that we outlined
during this webinar
for example we said that it's important
to ensure sufficient representation of
subpopulations in the data
but as we found in our own research with
our colleagues
hal dalmae and miro duda here at
microsoft and
our amazing intern ken holstein
sometimes it's not even easy to
identify what the most relevant sub
populations
are in a particular context or a
particular domain
let alone figure out how much data is
needed about each of them
we're actually going to be talking about
some of these research challenges in
more detail
in a tutorial that we are presenting
with an awesome group of colleagues
at the fat star conference next week in
atlanta
and this tutorial is going to be
available for a live stream as well so i
would encourage people to check it out
and i'd also refer people to our
upcoming chi paper
improving fairness and machine learning
systems what do
industry practitioners need where we've
outlined a lot of
research challenges that we think are
super important
yeah so just to reiterate what jen said
the most important thing
at least as we see it is research into
those processes and tools
to support practitioners in following
the kinds of best practices that we
mentioned
of course and at the risk of repeating
ourselves we
absolutely caution against tech
solutionism though
and we definitely want to remind people
that many of the most pressing
challenges
fall outside of computer science
so i'm just going to take a quick
opportunity to answer one more question
that i saw come in
which is as follows who should be
responsible for the fairness of the
system
this is a great question and i have a
very simple answer
everyone everyone involved in developing
and deploying that system
should feel responsible for its fairness
at the end of the day it's very
difficult to pinpoint
any one person who's making all of the
decisions
that go into developing or deploying a
machine learning system
so it's therefore very difficult to
pinpoint any one person who can be
responsible
for a systems fairness so at the end of
the day
this is on all of us to uh to take this
into account
yet i absolutely agree okay
so i think that's about all that we have
time for today i just want to thank all
of you
for coming and listening to this live
and sending us these great
questions and i hope that you all found
this very useful
thanks a lot